all right um by the way we will try and
make sure I think that there'll be links
to all of these people in descriptions
of the videos and things like that so
that you can go and find the amazing
work that's happening at Runway or just
follow up with these people find them on
Twitter see what's coming next
um okay and speaking of keeping up with
things uh our final guest for the
evening or morning wherever you are is a
polynario Paso
um apollonario is a machine learning
engineer or machine learning art
engineer I believe is the title uh
talking face and he's also an artist who
focuses on generative art and generative
media and for me the platform that he
founded multimodal.art and the company
Twitter account and things it's just a
really amazing resource in terms of
especially for people who are trying to
keep up with the space but don't
necessarily have time to be you know
tracking all these different sources a
pulmonary has done a really great job of
bringing the community together and kind
of curating and keeping track of what's
happening and sharing that with people
with the very infectious enthusias so
really great to have you here at
polynaria and I'm really looking forward
to hearing you know what comes after the
hype
you're muted uh probably
sorry Hi everyone uh thanks for the
introduction and yeah so I'm here to
talk about how diffusion models are cool
I think we've we've been through many
talks that show how they're cool
um but and there is a lot of a
generative media hype right now I think
more and more people are jumping people
are raising kind of big rounds just but
not just but like by implementing this
Technologies there are lots of lower
hanging fruits a lot of people jumping
into the space this is amazing
um so I'd like to give a panorama and
look into the future a little bit of
course with our sparse knowledge
um this first image here is actually an
analogy of the fusion models that I like
to make because if we think about
diffusion models when you start from
random noise and you make you end up
into an image it's kind of like this
quotation by Michelangelo that uh in the
in the block of stone uh he removes
everything that is not Stone to make the
angel right and this quotation is false
of course like everything on the
internet but I still like the analogy so
that's why I include this image every uh
talk I make
um I have this light here to go very
quickly to go very quickly on how
diffusion models work just uh to give a
ground
but I think the GIF is already played so
oh yeah so basically the the way the
future models work on a very high level
is that you train a model to go from uh
signal to know you add noise to an image
so you go into this direction and then
you train the model to go back into the
other direction so from random noise it
kind of finds the image behind on the
the noise if you want to learn more of
course you can join the
course that is the motivation
uh uh whole event here but before
talking about the future I'd like to
talk a little bit about the past
um before a software Creative Media
required manual and Ultra specialized
work to come to life right like
film editing required someone literally
with a scissor cutting
um the film right and then gluing them
together and you had like quite skilled
people
um that would actually uh glue them
together in very specific ways or in
Google uh seamless uh cuts and this was
a skill this was a profession this was
just a required step for making film
right like you'll have the film you have
to cut it you had to like
process it and there was no way around
it until software right like
when I think about software or anything
about computers and we can think of the
other Revolution that was brought up but
um with software essentially skilled
professionals can bring creative Works
to life faster right so the idea that
someone might have thought of cutting it
could not be applicable and now it is
and way more cutting and the editing
techniques are available because of this
and this allows for huge Productions
with a lot of bigger effects that were
only dreams of
of the techniques that were manual are
that were not yeah not digital or analog
um and when the barrier of Entry Lord a
creative explosion arose so I took this
chart of movies released per year and I
found like the year that digital cameras
and the door Premiere were uh kind of I
said invented but it's really like
released a digital cameras in the window
Premiere and we can see a creative
explosion uh right so
basically uh you had the limited amount
of people that could do film that could
produce creative output in the film
format and with the digital uh
Revolution essentially everyone
can with access to a camera into a
computer could learn the skill but it's
still a skill that you have to learn but
we can see that way more films were
produced so maybe the person that had
the profession of cutting the film
actually potentially uh that job became
very Niche but the overall film editing
uh profession
grow way more right
so well what if instead of days it took
seconds or in minutes to create and
everyone I think watching this talk may
be familiar that Dolly showed uh the
world texture image was possible
um but that was just the beginning
stable diffusion showed the the show the
potential of this technology when it
goes open source
um and how it can be simplified with
libraries like diffusers
um and now we're in an era of a
community customization of models so
people are doing dream Booth textual
inversion and other techniques and with
in less than one hour you can train a
model
and yeah there's even a newer technique
that you can train in only one image
called dream artist
um so it's pretty it's a pretty uh nice
way to customize the model so that's
that gives us a glimpse on the fact that
these models are open source released
and the community has jumped in and now
people are customizing it on different
things
um and yeah I also recommend to watch
this this video by Corridor Digital it's
very cool they essentially use dream
boots and a bunch of other visual
techniques to create uh the Spiderman
from from
from spider-verse into the whole Marvel
Cinematic Universe so this also gives a
glimpse on how this could be used
professionally in the future
um but
I would like to get a bit into some of
the philosophical debates if I may
um and I really like this this kind of
Twitter thread it's a bit old if you
think about if you see it uh April 8th
but I think it's still interesting in
one hand we have someone saying that
Dali broke their heart because
in this person's perspective
uh this kind of of technique of text to
image and the and broader would destroy
visual art because basically it would uh
essentially create so much of it that
the we wouldn't be able to to
differentiate beauty or to differentiate
um
yeah like that he even gives the analogy
of the more destructive than what they
connected to music right so from this
person's perspective essentially just by
creating uh an unlimited ish amount of
3D images or images that are tuned to
our brain to find catchy right in the
same way a music is catchy for some
people may not correlate to it being
good some people are worried that by
making catch your very beautiful looking
images instantly we would overload the
world with a with beauty and when
everything's beautiful nothing is
beautiful right so there is one side of
this uh
debate and on the other side of this
debate there is Claire silver which is a
a digital artist that's also used as
generative models that says that
actually this tools allow for creativity
without the barrier of skill that makes
everyone an artist essentially so saying
that the skill and the the labor and the
work is not the soul of art the soul of
heart has the creative expression and
this models enable everyone to to
express themselves creatively right I
think those are two sides of an argument
that
um exists in the world
um
and I won't take sides on this
particular slide because I think it's
worth for people to reflect on because
in one hand I do think that we when this
is used on advertisement industry we'll
see a saturation of beauty let's put it
that way but on the other hand I do
think that empowering people to create
is is amazing yeah
so yeah and I think on the same
capacity another big debate there is is
whether this technology will create more
jobs or it will remove more jobs I
actually I bring this creating more jobs
here because a lot of people
um are talking about so many professions
that could potentially be replaced by
this kind of Technology but I reinvite
everyone to look at this chart again
because in the same way I think that the
when digital cameras and the book
reviewer came together
uh this exploded the production of
things right I do think that when this
technology is matured enough to be on
everyone's devices there's so many new
content new productions being made that
a whole new industry might boom and in
the same way that YouTube for example is
a is a platform where people can kick
start their own thing and uh and reach
an audience I believe that an analogous
process or or a curve even more
exponential than this could uh just
create way more a whole new economy
right so maybe in the same way that the
job of the person Cuts in the film
disappeared but the the overall video
editing the jobs actually got way more I
do think that even if you don't know the
names or or how to frame them yet that
just the creative explosion this is
bringing about and how much more content
can be produced how many more people can
express themselves would lead to
potentially more jobs in this overall
economy despite maybe some operational
processes being uh challenged uh in a
way but at the same time it's quite it's
kind of unavoidable that this technology
is getting embedded into tools that's
designers use so I do think that it's a
co-creation process that in some areas
may need slightly less professionals but
overall I think it can boom a new
economy with more people participating
than before
um
and yeah I think overall it's just a
radically different world where you're
going to live in because uh yeah you
imagine the kids saying that we're so
old that computers didn't even know how
to draw and they grew up right so when
this is Baseline right when this
technology is uh the basis for things
when this is obvious that computers can
do it
we will start operating on other layers
right so right now this this technology
is impressive to us we want to improve
it we want to make the video we wanted
to make audio once this is like Baseline
we'll not be thinking so much about the
video right I think a lot of this
technology is about the medium and you
do like a frog jumping from a building
with the clothes of
Superman just because you want to make
sure like I think this crazy problems
are in part doesn't wanting to make sure
that those images were not in the data
set right like that it's really creating
and uh and but once we overcome that and
we really use this into our our creative
process
um there is a radically different world
I believe that that is about to come and
I I'm taking a few wild guesses here
about what could potentially come and
one thing that we can see converging is
automatic script generation with the
language models and then video
generation as well so you can imagine a
script being written by an AI and then
the script is becoming a whole video
animation by an AI and then all the the
voices acting also being generated by an
AI and if we combine this together I
could think of a Netflix
that is custom right so we could think
of something like
you have TV shows or a series that are
generated for you all right and some
people may think that's amazing some
people may think that's horrible some
people may think oh this will create
even Echo chambers of size one right
but I do think that uh there are that
this is a possibility that we could have
a generative customized and maybe even
together let's say you and your partner
it makes a TV show that both of you like
so it's like combines the faces of the
the two of you or or a group of friends
so yeah I think the possibilities are
endless but I do think that
ungenerated auto-generated end-to-end
content based on your taste is something
that could be in the Horizon and for
some is uh is a Utopia hedonistic
utopian for others can be like a
nightmare so up to you but I think some
something in this capacity could exist
another one is and by the way this image
was generated by stable diffusion 2 so
quite like it
um I do think that uh
social media wouldn't have to look
radically different to support a world
where everyone is creating right like
imagine
uh just the the volume of content
created by the imagination of people
with this tools
um I'm not sure that the the current
social media Twitter Instagram Facebook
or even like the the messaging apps like
WhatsApp would support
um the not support technically maybe
they could increase their bandwidth but
I'm talking about ux UI like would the
platforms that exist today
um be compatible with a world where
everyone is creating everyone is being
creative
um I think not and I think new platforms
would if the current platforms don't
adapt they could be leapfrogged by new
platforms that
has to have this in their core right so
I think that's something that we will
have to see to but I it's another point
that I believe
could make sense in the future and yeah
um I would like to uh and here to open
for questions and to ask what do you
create and happy to yeah take questions
from the audience and also reflect a
little bit on the points that I brought
awesome thanks Paulie for this uh
provocative talk
um there's a question here for I mean
it's more of a comment than maybe a
question but we can turn it into a
question so
from shubham who says
you know at some point we can imagine
that you know there's uh sort of
generated images are going to be almost
as good or indistinguishable from um you
know the ones that humans have made
and I guess it's sort of asking like
maybe like one does it matter and two
like do we do we want to sort of aim or
optimize for a future where that is is
the case or you know what's your
thoughts on like you know the future of
like a lot of say Google search suddenly
now returning generated images versus
you know human generated ones
yeah I think that's a very provocative
question and I I would say there is a
twofold answer to it uh one is that
indeed I think very soon
um
will be failing the string test of
whether or not uh what we're seeing is
an AI generated image or a real picture
um although I think our brains are very
good at uh being adversario in that so I
think we it will be a a bit of a
cataract catch game for a bit but I do
think at the end the
it will blend in but I do believe that
actually and it's a bit of a side-ended
from the question but I do believe that
there is a there is a a size to this
which is I do think that
um new art style by humans will emerge
on the failures of this this model so
basically
we can think of what what can stay with
the fusion not to hands right so like
let's change drawing hands girls in
popularity or something like that and of
course hence is is a dumb example but I
do believe that there will be a bit of
an adversarial gain between human
artists and and this AIS and we'll we
might see because once the AI generated
content is everywhere media advertising
Google search Etc I do think this will
create an opportunity for artists to say
how can I create something that is
radically different from the entire
universe of what this AIS can do and I
think there is there there will be a set
that is outside of that right that
humans could explore at least
temporarily then someone goes and trains
the AI into that whatever new thing and
it becomes like a a game but I do
believe that uh we when if we get
saturated people will try to overcome
the saturation be it with a human
created stuff or either yeah created
stuff but I wouldn't say we should I
mean
I I do think that us humans are very
adaptable to things in a way in the
sense of
um it it can be like some people can
like oh it's if we cannot distinguish
it's the end of things you know like we
we've heard this uh kind of Doomsday
Prophecy Before and they maybe they may
have some truth to them but I do think
we're very adaptable and once uh we take
taken as true that okay like generative
uh our media and real photos are are now
indistinguishable in the same way that
uh Photoshop artists can do really
indistinguishable images from real ones
and we still have like social cues to
distinguish things like very unlikely uh
a reputable newspaper will publish a
photoshopped image of a Leo event right
I think we will create social
um
structures to make sure that the source
of things and where where things come
from and who posted it and how this was
so this came about
um yeah so I I'm not too worried about
that but I do think that uh we need to
socially build the the structures
together because it's not only about the
output right it's about
yeah totally and we saw in Debbie's talk
actually this discussion about you know
the data set and how do you construct
data sets that are in you know some way
fair to the artists and it's like a kind
of sociological question right
so I have another question maybe for
myself which is um
one of the one of the things that's like
surprising about diffusion models is
that for someone like myself who lived
or lives in Transformer land it kind of
came out of nowhere so you know I was
happily going along with large language
models NLP and now a little bit of
multimodal stuff and then boom you know
stable diffusion kind of lands right and
there were these like hints of like you
know clip and glide and of course we
knew Dali from from open AI
um and the question I have for you is
like um
why do you think it took so long so to
speak to go from like you know these
sort of original diffusion papers some
of them which I think are quite old like
you know maybe even 10 years
um to get to where we are now because it
doesn't seem like it was like oh we
needed like you know the Transformer or
something to make this work it's more
like you know this kind of kind of
Frankenstein combination of existing
tools
and I was just curious what you thought
on that is like was it a surprise to you
as someone who's been in the generative
art scene you saw this coming or was it
something that um also you know kind of
surprised you
yeah um so I think the first paper that
I know of for the fusion models is from
2016 which is like ages ago on the on
the space right
um and it's very interesting because it
was like uh an exploratory process of oh
we can use this this technique from
thermodynamics because uh yeah diffusion
models like are called diffusion models
because of gas diffusions right like
some people may not be aware of that but
um when like basically in the original
diffusion models paper they train the
model to like basically take a 2d plane
and imagine if I guess was like
spreading from an S shape from this
really plane and like training to go
back to the shape because gases are
chaotic in nature right like usually
they go everywhere so denoising this
this process is hard and they they try
to use it as a machine learning
technique and it was kind of like a cool
experiment got some traction at the time
but it didn't perform better than
anything that was still there at the
time so people it went kind of dormant
and then I think it revived around 2019
with uh Jonathan Hall's paper on on
the
I am
and essentially that's that recreated
and twisted into it and I think it was
kind of so this way I think there was
like this small winter let's say of like
three years of little interest but since
this paper I think uh the interest
picked up and because I think uh in this
in this paper it was already
a bit competitive to what Gans would do
and how games would work so I do think
this technique
um was like not right not not
necessarily with Transformers but like
little bit with the cans but I do think
that what transformed kind of everything
in this space was the Dali one blog post
and and included paper because I think
just the framework that you could
condition uh
generative models in general in text was
something that was explored very
minimally and no one really thought it
wasn't anywhere close to being like high
quality right like to type in a text and
fully generate the image like maybe you
could drive in some directions and some
people are thinking of this with uh
with uh Gans like style games and stuff
but really the release of cliff and the
in the in the oh and the
a general uh open AI thing uh of of
Dolly transform this this I think and
that kind of created a I think like
Robin's and Patrick work like VQ again
combined with clip and then images
started being generated that open AI
picked up on the on the diffusion model
work
um for for
with their paper called the fusionsbit
again on image synthesis and that
brought a lot of attention
and then yeah people from the generative
media Community like Catherine Carlson
uh hooked together this model right like
the the fusion and clip and this
clip-guided diffusion process showed
that diffusion had a lot of potential
for for generative media and then open
AI picked up from that with the Glide
and then Dolly 2 and the Google and
stable diffusion also picked up on on on
those uh works so I do believe that uh
there there was a convergence in time
but yeah I think it's like with many of
the things in science are are a bit
pneumatic in the sense of the ideas that
pick up because of other ideas and yeah
the technique was there dormant but I
think it it emerged in the time where it
made sense also from GPU
some people even say it's it arrived too
early in a sense because we like if if
we were in a new iteration of gpus when
this technique existed this could have
seen a different explosion because more
people could train it on their own
Hardware because it's like yeah
not accessible to train so if this
creates like a scenario that we see
where big organizations even if they're
nice big organizations like having a
face or stability AI to train things for
open source
um still not that other big
organizations are not nice but just the
ones that were these things open source
versus not but you still require like
you cannot train uh state-of-the-art
model in your
in your house like you could do it again
right so
um it I think it came at the right time
where it was possible to make a model
with the quality that is so in a way it
kind of balances out like even with
neural networks right like it's there's
a lot of people asking me this question
and why it took so long to think of uh
given this always existed in computer
science history but
yeah I guess it's like the thing we were
talking with David that you know the the
criteria is can it run on collab and
that's like a a great you know unlocking
of of you know you send creativity